I'm announcing that earlier this morning
we have filed an official complaints
under the Convention on the Rights of
the child's world leaders don't like
being told what to do much less by a
group of schoolchildren including a
certain Swedish teenager who've decided
to take them to court my name is Ilya
Totenberg
I am 16 years old and I'm doing this
because world leaders are failing to
protect the rights of the child by
continuing to ignore the climate and
ecological crisis a summit on climate
change is the centerpiece of this year's
General Assembly and Greta tunberg it's
standout star it's a shift in emphasis
for secretary-general Antonia Guterres
who came to office focusing on conflict
resolution but instead has watched peace
escaped the likes of Syria Yemen and
Libya with a new conflict looming in the
Gulf it is that sense of urgency but I
have to say the secretary-general didn't
do it alone I think all you had to do is
watch the millions of people especially
young people that were in the streets on
Friday and the secretary-general is
fully aware that he may have been
speaking but in the back there were
millions of young people screaming and
pushing and demanding action that it
takes children to call world leaders to
account on something like climate change
says a lot about the state of global
diplomacy as it does about the ever more
elusive search for consensus that the UN
and this vast gathering are supposed to
be about 193 countries represented more
than 500 side events a blizzard of
activity but how much can actually be
achieved former diplomat and UN weapons
inspector Richard Butler anyone who
walks into an assembly like this and
thinks that I can get what I want from
it selfishly and take it away put it in
my poverty
is not living on the same planet that
I'm living on interdependence is the
name of the game finding solutions that
suit a larger rather than a smaller
number of people is what this place is
about and the moral imperative to do so
is the key thing that an assembly of
this magnitude mobilize the imperative
to act on climate change is not shared
by President Trump who attended a
parallel meeting on religious freedoms
instead a deliberate attempt to divert
attention from a cause he doesn't
believe in critics said an attempt that
doesn't appear to have worked
Jonah Hall al Jazeera at the UN in New
York